TAKING IT SERIOUSLY.
RICK, THANK YOU.
ALSO BREAKING TONIGHT, NEW
DRAMA UNFOLDING IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM AS THE
COUNTRY'S PRIME MINISTER
TRIES TO FORGE A DEAL TO
LEAVE THE EUROPEAN UNION.
BRITISH PRIME MINISTER BORIS
JOHNSON SUFFERING A MAJOR
DEFEAT IN PARLIAMENT WITHIN
JUST THE LAST TWO HOURS AS
LAWMAKERS VOTE TO TAKE
CONTROL OF THE BREXIT
AGENDA.
THE PRIME MINISTER
IMMEDIATELY THREATENING TO
CALL FOR A NEW GENERAL
ELECTION THERE, WHICH, IF IT
HAPPENED, WOULD BE THAT
COUNTRY'S THIRD GENERAL
ELECTION IN FOUR YEARS.
SENIOR FOREIGN AFFAIRS
CORRESPONDENT AMY KELLOGG
LIVE IN LONDON TONIGHT WITH
THE BREAKING NEWS AND
LEGISLATIVE CHAOS.
GOOD EVENING, AMY.
>> HI, BRET, YES.
BORIS JOHNSON DID CALL FOR A
NEW GENERAL ELECTION AFTER
THE PARLIAMENT RESTED
CONTROL OF THE BREXIT
PROCESS IN AN ATTEMPT, BRET,
TO KEEP THE U.K. CRASHING
OUT OF THE EUROPEAN UNION
WITHOUT A DEAL ON
OCTOBER 31st.
>> BORIS JOHNSON LOST HIS
WORKING MAJORITY TUESDAY
WHEN ONE OF HIS M.P.s
SWITCHED SIDES.
SOME OTHER CONSERVATIVES
DECLARED THEIR INTENTION TO
VOTE TO PREVENT THEIR PRIME
MINISTER LEAVING THE EU
WITHOUT A DEAL IN PLACE.
JOHNSON WARNED IF PARLIAMENT
CLIPPED HIS WINGS HE WOULD
HAVE TO SEND BRITS MORE
DIVIDED THAN EVER BACK TO
THE BALLOT.
>> WE DON'T WANT AN EXIT.
WE WANT TO GET THE DEAL DONE
AND THE BEST WAY, THE BEST
WAY, MR. SPEAKER, TO GET A
DEAL IS TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> JOHNSON CLAIMED ANY
ATTEMPT TO BLOCK A NO DEAL
BREXIT WOULD HURT HIS
ONGOING EFFORT TO GET 11TH
HOUR CONCESSIONS FROM THE EU
FOR A DIVORCE DEAL.
AND HE THREATENED TO CHUCK
THOSE VOTING AGAINST HIM OUT
OF THE CONSERVATIVE PARTY.
AND THE PRIME MINISTER
ACCUSED THOSE WHO WOULD BEG
BRUSSELS FOR A FURTHER
EXTENSION TO THE BREXIT
DEADLINE OF SURRENDERING.
>> IF ANYTHING, IT IS A NO
DEAL EXIT THAT WOULD MEAN
SURRENDERING OUR INDUSTRY,
OUR JOBS.
SURRENDERING OUR PROTECTION
IN A TRADE DEAL WITH DONALD
TRUMP AND THE UNITED STATES.
>> YOU KNOW, BRET, BORIS
JOHNSON HAD SAID ALL ALONG
HE THOUGHT IT WAS INCUMBENT
UPON HIM TO DELIVER THE
RESULTS OF THAT REFERENDUM
WHICH TOOK PLACE THREE YEARS
AGO EVEN WITHOUT A DEAL TO
GET OUT OF EUROPEAN UNION AT
LONG LAST.
BUT NOW HE SAYS HE HAS NO
CHOICE BUT TO PUT IT TO THE
PEOPLE, HAVE THEM CHOOSE
WHICH LEADER THEY WOULD LIKE
TO SEND TO BRUSSELS TO HAVE
ANOTHER GO AT NEGOTIATIONS.
FINAL TWIST THOUGH, BRET,